cinéma littérature église politique
maintenant sport le milieu sportif est
il le nouveau terrain de jeu des
agressions sexuelles
depuis les révélations de l'ex patineuse
sarah abitbol dans son livre un si long
silence les langues se délient un tabou
est il en train de tomber
250 enquêtes sont ouvertes dans le
patinage selon la ministre des sports
oksana maracineanu et d'autres sports
sont concernés
natation équitation tennis football
entre entraîneurs criminelle et
éducateurs courroux d'un côté entre
fédération accusée de déviance
systémique et il ya ceux qui ferment les
yeux de l'autre tient emprise
psychologique sur les athlètes et sur
les victimes à qui appartient le corps
d'un sportif comment lutter contre ce
fléau on en parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un
nouveau numéro de l'autre au match après
les révélations de sarah abitbol est la
démission de didier gailhaguet le
président de la fédération française des
sports de glace place à un numéro
spécial violences sexuelles dans le
sport pour en parler nos invités sur ce
plateau
véronique le bar médecin et président du
comité éthique et sport est à vos côtés
béatrice barbusse sociologue du sport
première femme présidente d'un club de
sport professionnel masculin lui est si
vrai handball et auteur du livre du
sexisme dans le sport aux éditions en un
mot ça bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur sur ce plateau
depuis donc l'équipe du 29 janvier
dernier depuis les révélations de sarah
abitbol dans son livre un si long
silence
il y a eu en se souvient les vagues mitu
balance comporte ici on a l'impression
qu'il y à une nouvelle vague
véronique le bar dans le sport
l'institution du sport pourquoi est-elle
défaillante pourquoi maintenant alors
elle est pourquoi maintenant cela sort
c'est ça va nous y voilà
ben je pense que oui tout à fait le lit
de l'enquêtre disclose et disclose a
fait le lit de delà du livre de sarah
abitbol est tout tout tout ces
phénomènes font que maintenant cela sort
bien que ça existe depuis toujours
vous parlez de l'enquète disclose qui
s'appelle pédophilie dont le sport le
scandale on en diffusera deux extraits
au cours de cette émission
béatrice dans cette enquête 28 sports
sont concernés il n'y a donc pas que le
patinage artistique
pourquoi dans cette enquête il est
stipulé cette question pourquoi les
instances préfère soutenir les
entraîneur d'evian qui apporte des
médailles plutôt que des victimes
pourquoi selon vous selon moi parce que
dans ces affaires de violences sexuelles
il met à mal ce qui est le fondement du
sport à savoir ses valeurs le sport
aujourd'hui même le sport business se
vend sur à partir d'un certain nombre de
valeurs de partage de solidarité de
respect d'humanisme et c'est tout sauf
ce qu'il y a dans ces cas de violences
sexuelles
quand vous allez donc c'est pour taire
c'est pour protéger l'image du sport
sauf que on idéalise un peu trop souvent
parfois le sport et que le sport n'est
n'est pas forcément bien l'espoir est un
outil donc il est bien ou mauvais en
fonction de la manière dont les hommes
et des femmes que nous sommes
l'utilisent et donc là en l'occurrence
vous mettez à maj ne vous mettez à mal
l'image du sport donc on essaye
d'étouffer on essaye de ne rien voir
ça c'est un élément d'explication pour
lequel on n'en parle pas on n'a pas
parlé jusqu'à présent il ya un autre
élément d'explication aussi pour lequel
on en a pas parlé jusqu'à maintenant et
pourquoi ça sort juste maintenant mais
c'est parce que c'est un milieu
extrêmement masculin et que cette
question là ce que je constate moi sur
le terrain n'est pas forcément une
priorité masculine n'est pas un sujet
qui je pourrai faudrait peut-être penser
que c'est caricatural est ce que je dis
mais je le vis hélas et beaucoup
notamment depuis dix jours depuis que
ces affaires sortent
voilà il ya des propos qui me laisse
penser que c'est ça pas été toujours une
priorité
et donc il ya aussi cette volonté de
préserver cette figure troisièmement de
l'entraîneur tout puissant qui va amener
un potentiel vers l'extraordinaire vers
la médaille vers le titre et donc c'est
aussi ça qui fait vendre l'image d'un
club l'image d'une fédération l'image
d'un sport quand vous gagnez vous est
visible et ce qu'ils font gagner
ce sont souvent des entraîneurs puisque
ce sont eux qui organisent la production
de la performance sportive devons qu'on
va tout faire surtout quand il s'agit
comme c'est le cas de sarah abitbol d'un
entraîneur qui a des résultats sportifs
donc là on va tout faire pour protéger
avant tout le résultat
tif et on met de côté bas hélas l'aspect
humain en l'occurrence là pourquoi
canton mais davantage sur le plan en
avant le plan sportif et pas le plan
humain pourquoi c'est pour derrière
obtenir je sais pas des subventions de
la part de l'état parce qu'on gagne du
coup c'est une question d'argent au
final c'est la performante papuda
tellement d'argent c'est la performance
et les médailles c'est laura c'est la
politique c'est une économie qui
découlent de tout ça et c'est vrai que
le corps est un objet surtout dans le
sport de haut niveau c'est un objet
c'est un outil de performance et il est
réduit à ça justement vous dit le corps
est un objet à qui appartient le corps
est ce qu il appartient à l'athlète est
ce qu il appartient à l'entraîneur la
fédération voire au pays quand on ramène
des médailles olympiques
pour moi il appartient l'athlète un
corps nous appartient
mon corps m'appartient votre corps vous
appartient le vôtre aussi vous
appartient il t'appartient absolument
pas ni à la nation ni à la fédération ni
à l'entraîneur encore moins à
l'entraîneur sauf que vous avez raison
de le dire c'est qu'on a tendance à
considérer qu'il nous appartient ça
c'est vrai et on
du coup et surtout dans des relations il
ya quelque chose de particulier dans la
relation entraîneur entraîné et a une
triple domination il ya la domination de
la figure de l'entraîneur sur l'entraîné
sur l'athlète d'accord parce qu'il faut
savoir que l'entraîneur a une position
très sacralisé dans le monde du sport
c'est encore une fois celui qui produit
la performance s'il n'est pas là y'a
rien s'il n'est pas là y'a rien il faut
également savoir que pendant longtemps
il n'y a pas eu d'entrée dans le métier
d'entraîneur est un métier qui date des
années en france je parle le métier
d'entraîneur c'est quelque chose qui
s'est développée surtout après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
dire que le sport quand il s'est
développé en france y avait pas
d'entraîneur il ya vait l'athlète est le
président et c'était souvent les
athlètes c'est de là que vient
d'ailleurs au rugby le dernier
entraînement avant un match qui est fait
par le capitaine de l'équipe c'est
souvent celui qui travaille et que tu es
professeur donc les entraîneurs ont
commencé à arriver dans les années 20 30
dans le foot et puis après dans les
années après la deuxième guerre mondiale
et donc il a fallu qu'ils soient à la
recherche d'une légitimité d'une classe
positionne dans l'est dans l'écosystème
du sport est la seule façon bien
évidemment et c'est pour ça qu'ils
existent ils ont ils ont été mis en
place pour quoi pour améliorer la
performance
pour qu'on soit meilleur donc
aujourd'hui c'est une figure qui est
central dans l'écosystème c'est c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est souvent
sacralisé donc on ne veut pas le toucher
et d'ailleurs vous voyez bien qu'au fil
des années en tout cas moi c'est ce que
j'ai pu observer parce que j'ai trop si
un ouvrage sur les entraîneurs sportifs
professionnels au fil des années on voit
bien que la place de l'entraîneur est de
plus en plus prégnante est importante au
sein du sport oms les interviewe leur
salaire arrive au même niveau sinon ils
sont aussi tout aussi importants voire
plus important que que celle que
leur salaire que ceux des athlètes et
c'est donc c'est un personnage clip
auquel on doit pas toucher
et puis il ya aussi la domination
adultes enfants qu'on retrouve dans
l'éducation nationale qu'on peut
retrouver dans l'église donc il ya cette
domination à espiet 23e la domination de
l'homme sur la femme
vous avez toutes les conditions qui sont
réunies pour que hélas ce genre de
phénomènes se produisent au 130e regarde
l'enquète de disclose envoie également
qu'il y a des garçons qui sont victimes
également social 20 % de garçons qui
sont victimes de violences sexuelles et
je pense qu'il faut vraiment pas les
oublier et vraiment pas nous réduire la
problématique des violences sexuelles
uniquement un rapport homme femme parce
que déjà que les les femmes les victimes
femmes n'arrivent pas enfin ont beaucoup
de mal à parler à se libérer justement
de cette parole qui est qui qui qui qui
les rend qui les rend muette
les garçons eux parlent encore moins
parce que ce sont des garçons comme
total comme disait tout à l'heure
béatrice qui sont jeunes qui sont
adolescents enfants jeunes adultes et
qui peut être se cherche au niveau et
qui se cherche et et kiki et on met le
doute quelque part dans leur tête
est-ce que je suis est ce que je suis
homosexuel et on sait que dans le monde
du sport il ya une grande homophobie
donc se rajoute en plus de la
culpabilité de toute victime dans le
sport hors sport dans l'église etc etc
de toute vie toutes victimes se sont
coupables mais en plus pour ces garçons
qui parle qui ne parle pratiquement pas
à la différence des filles qui parlent
juste un tout petit peu plus ces garçons
se dit seront non plus 7 ce tabou sur la
tête de l'homophobie
donc vraiment il ne faut surtout pas les
oublier et surtout c'est important ce
que vous cela vous vous souvenez de
tezuka est fondamentale en effet du côté
de la victime n'y a pas de différence
soit un homme ou une femme est
d'ailleurs dans le sport la quête qui
avait été fait en 2009 par le ministère
des sports montré parmi les sportifs de
haut niveau qui avait autant de filles
que de garçons qui étaient victimes de
ce genre d'agression
d'accord en revanche du côté des
prédateurs sexuels
incontestablement à plus de 90 95 % sont
des hommes sont souvent des prédateurs
sexuels et non pas des prédatrice
sexuelle
donc là il ya des c'est un fait qui
questionne dans un environnement qui est
le sport qui l'a aussi dominé par les
hommes il ya une culture est arrivé
c'est la logique qu'il faut comprendre
il ya une culture viriliste et donc je
reviens ce que 10 à véronique une
culture viriliste qui donne pour
injonction à vous messieurs d'être de
vrais hommes des hommes courageux d'être
dans une
dans un rapport fort dominant et quand
vous faites agresser sexuellement quand
vous fait violer sexuellement
vous n'êtes plus dominants vous êtes
dans une situation dominée donc c'est un
aveu de faiblesse
c'est un aveu de défaite même pour un
jeune garçon que de dire ah ben moi dans
cette société où on nous montre partout
que je dois être le mâle dominant ou là
c'est moi qui me suis fait agresser et
c'est moi qui devient domine et hélas la
parole elle est difficile
comment voulez-vous que ils ont cette
double pression les jeunes garçons mais
tout ça pour dire aussi que c'est lié
quand même à cette culture sexistes et
viriliste du sport qu'il existait
phénomène là parce que on considère et
souvent on a parlé plusieurs fois il ya
même des agressions entre athlètes
maintenant comment comment c'est
possible que des athlètes masculins les
hommes puissent avoir ce comportement
avec des athlètes femmes
c'est bien qu'il ya une culture où nous
dit il y a un rapport avec le sexe y ait
un rapport avec le corps et un rapport
avec la femme et avec la souffrance et
avec la souffrance qui doit être
questionné quand même de ce côté là et
et aux conduits sous vent que le sport
reflète la société
certes mais alors il reflète la société
mais il en dit aussi
allons jusqu'au bout alors de cette
logique oui reflète la société
on a une culture extrêmement vers élise
dans notre société française
particulièrement et qui se reflète bien
évidemment le mans dans le sport puisque
le sport est une activité qui a été fait
par les hommes et pour les hommes pour
qu'ils apprennent à être des autres et
que pour vous appreniez à le rester donc
donc c'est pas quand même complètement
détachée de cette question égalité homme
femme
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est que je pense très sincèrement je
fais l'hypothèse et s'il y avait
beaucoup
plus de femmes dans le milieu sportif à
des poses de direction a déposé
d'entraîneur à déposer arbitres on
aurait très certainement moins deux
phénomènes de violences sexuelles
quand j'ai eu un cas depuis de
criminalité dans mon club à l us ivry
handball comme vous l'avez cité il ya
maintenant douze ans l'avocat qui était
à mes côtés m'a dit madame barbus si
vous voulez pas avoir d'ennuis avec les
petits vous mettez des femmes
entraîneurs ou des entraîneuses sauf que
le problème c'est que n'a pas
suffisamment donc du coup on ferme les
yeux dès qu'on trouve un bénévole
derrière il est difficile d'en trouver
un c'est ça on a on a beaucoup de mal à
trouver des bénévoles dans le dans le
monde du sport est donc donc la question
du b2 est une question essentielle
il faut le faire il faut demander le b2c
c'est très clairement c'est quoi le b2c
le bulletin numéro deux du casier
judiciaire qui montre les condamnations
pénales
enfin les graves condamnation d'une
personne je vous coupe c'est la pause
on en reparle dans un instant à rester
sur rt france que trimestre revient très
vite de retour sur le plateau de l'autre
match spécial violences sexuelles dont
le sport sur ce plateau véronique le bar
toujours présente
la présidente du comité éthique et
sports à vos côtés
béatrice barbusse sociologue du sport il
ya eu
une tribune de 54 athlètes du cnosf le
comité national de l'olympisme du sport
français qui est voit qu'un des mesures
en les voit ici donc créé une cellule
d'écouté indépendant de vérifier les
extraits de casier judiciaire révoquer
les personnes impliquées dans les
affaires dites d'agression sexuelle mais
dans l'édito de jérôme cazes à dieu dans
l'équipe du 29
janvier dernier il écrivait justement
que dans l'équipe il était écrit il faut
renforcer le contrôle des encadrants
exiger un extrait de casier judiciaire
comptant des cantons en quatre démineurs
ça c'était il ya neuf ans ils l'ont
écrit
dix ans après qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi ça n'avance pas d'évoquer la
question juridique donc celle là je
pense qu'elle est très compliqué et très
complexe et j'ai peur que mercredi
dernier on a eu que des effets d'annoncé
parce que autour de moi je n'entends que
des gens qui disent que ça va pas être
possible de le faire
ok moi je suis pas juriste je suis pas
spécialiste informaticienne je ne sais
pas comment ça fonctionne et un truc
donc on va attendre
donc il ya le volet juridique c'est une
chose mais ne résoudra pas tout donc
après il ya les quais tout ce que fait
notamment comme éthique et sport donc il
ya la prévention il ya de
l'accompagnement il y à de la formation
et de la sensibilisation des dirigeants
des entraîneurs des jeunes justement la
fédération française d'équitation il ya
quelques jours vient de faire une
affiche pour sensibiliser ses
pratiquants on la voit d'arrière-goût
n'en parlait pas car votre cheval oui
alors écoutez les affiches on a vu ça
dans la lutte antidopage
on a vu ça dans toutes les préventions
une affiche on l'a on l'appela tarder
on est bien avec sa conscience parce
qu'on a dit qu'on a fait la prévention
et ça ne sert strictement à rien mais
c'est la préfère qu'on arrête avec des
affiches avec des choses de grippe
oui ou un peu importe ça ne sert à rien
il faut se prendre par la main qu'il
faut travailler il fait il faut
accompagner les athlètes
il faut il faut les accompagner
juridiquement psychologiquement
médicalement socialement et il faut il
faut mouiller la chemise
il faut ça veut dire dans la réaction
plutôt que dans l'action à la moi j'ai
même toujours là pour moi c'est de la
communication qui ne sert à rien c'est
du buzz communicationnel qui ne sert
absolument à rien arthur en revanche
aller faire des actions de
sensibilisation d'information auprès des
jeunes dans les clubs auprès des parents
auprès des enfants des dirigeants pardon
des entraîneurs par le biais
d'associations par le biais de gens qui
sont formés à ça qu'ils sont experts il
ya tout un tas d'associations qui font
ça partout donc il faut faire appel à
ces associations à ces gens qui ont
l'habitude de parler à des enfants parce
qu'on ne dit pas n'importe quoi non plus
à ces gens qui ont l'habitude et ouais
il faut il faut aussi ce contact il faut
parce que pour prendre conscience
vous savez moi j'ai je suis une femme
alors peut-être que j'en ai près plus
conscience que d'autres parce
qu'effectivement les violences les
féminicides ça concerne surtout les
femmes mais mais surtout quand une femme
vient vous pleuré dans les bras qui
vient vous expliquer qu'elle a subi un
viol je pouvais pas l'oublier vous
pouvez pas l'oublier et là vous
comprenez bien que si vous voulez être
vrai ta ble ment sensibilisés à la
question rien ne vaut quelqu'un par
exemple qui a vécu sestak vendre le
livre de de sart à moi je peux
j'aimerais bien que tous les dirigeants
du sport français le lisent utilisent
des parfois des mots franchement vous
avez du mal parfois à tourner la page
il faut qu'ils hissent livrant sans il
faut que tout le monde comprenne les
douleurs les souffrances par lesquels
passent ces gens ce sont des vies qui
sont détruites
ça fait vingt trente ans maintenant
vingt ans vingt trente ans qu'elle prend
des antidépresseurs d un type vous vous
rendez compte
elle peut pas prendre le train elle peut
pas prendre l'avion elle peut pas être
dans des lieux seule elle est
traumatisée à vie comme toutes ces
victimes
ce livre a changé beaucoup de choses est
en train de faire bouger les lignes en a
parlé également de l'anc est de 10 close
de file dans le sport le scandale on
parle de ce coup franc je propose de
regarder un extrait d'un père qui lui
aussi a beaucoup souffert et qui du coup
ne s'est pas forcément quoi faire quand
il se retourne face aux autorités
regardez l'extrait j'appelais donc le
commissariat pour le père de pauline il
ne fait aucun doute que l'entraîneur va
être envoyé en prison
il contacte immédiatement le président
du club pour le prévenir du viol présumé
de sa fille
sa réponse est à peine croyable quand
j'appelle il dit va je suis pas surpris
de notre appel téléphonique jeudi ont
été un petit peu que norilsk problème là
il me dit j'avais des échos donc de cet
entraîneur ils me disent vraiment à
toury nombreux voilà le père pense que
le club va réagir mais ils se trompent
bonjour pouvez vous me dire quand elles
vous déposer plainte
merci signé donc le président donc moi j
répondant dans la foulée donc bonjour
monsieur voilà nous allons déposer
plainte donc à se rendre ce jour à 16
heures à la brigade des mineurs de notre
département
je pense qu'il prend l'affairé au
sérieux mais très rapidement on se rend
compte qu'il ya plus de son est plus
d'image rapidement donc quand vous lisez
des clous venant du club
madeleine de leur parent soutient déjà
psychologique et de l'aide des ventes au
mans juridique elle de leur part
finalement rien
béatrice véronique vous parliez de
détresse on voit la détresse là d'un
père qui tombe face à un mur il ne sait
pas vers qui se retourner
est-ce que ce qui s'est passé récemment
la démission de didier gailhaguet les
annonces de roxana maracineanu quand
même 200 enquêtes lancées dans le
patinage sur la ministre des sports est
ce que ça peut faire changer les choses
est ce que ça va faire bouger les lignes
est-ce que ce père peut se dire que plus
tard il aura une réponse ou d'autres
personnes victimes de ceux là auront des
réponses ça peut être un catalyseur
ça peut être uniquement un catalyseur
mais là maintenant il faut prendre les
choses en main et travaillez pas faire
d'effet d'annoncé pas faire de
saupoudrage permettre d'afficher mur il
faut travailler fondamentalement et
surtout pas sortir de mesurettes qui ne
serviront à rien et qui justement sont
contre-productives c'est très important
qu'il faut des moyens
oui il faut des moyens il faut des
moyens et quand vous dites moyens ça
peut se chiffrer
comment est-ce que c'est par des
chiffres est ce que c'est par de
l'argent comment est ce que quand vous
dites vernis comme le bayern fait
intervenir quelqu'un il faut bien
rémunérer c'était cette personne bien
rémunérés donc vous allez admettons que
c'est pas que ça coûte 500 euros il ya
300 milliards en france
faites le calcul que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est la panique car on espère
bien sûr que tout ça va changer les
choses
y'a un moment de panique lance moment
parmi les dirigeants
tout le monde se réunit pour dire on
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc oui
ça a été utile savez aujourd'hui
j'entends des membres qui ce qui me font
mal an certains disent dans le milieu du
sport à faut arrêter avec cette hystérie
médiatique où ce buzz médiatique
mais comment on peut parler comme ça
comment on peut parler comme ça de 2,2
au mais heureusement que ces victimes
qui se met à parler aujourd'hui c'est
pas de l'hystérie c'est pas un buzz
c'est la réalité
on a voulu cacher et qui les années et
qui doit gérer ça et quand on dit mettre
de l'argent est ce que c'est vraiment
une volonté politique ou moi il n'y a
pas qu'une question d'argent il ya et il
ya aussi une question de professionnels
et de personnes qui connaissent la
problématique
un fauve vraiment mettre les gens autour
de la table enfin les gens des
professionnels qui connaissent cette
problématique autour de la table et
travailler etc
pas en deux semaines qu'on va sortir des
mesures il faut travailler faire des
études faire des conclusions évaluer et
agir et travailler sur ses causes
fondamentales
il ya dans le système du sport il ya
fondamentalement dans ses fondations
le nid de ce qui permet actuellement à
ce que ces violences sexuelles soit dans
une omerta complète
est ce que le ministère peut créer
quelque chose pour avoir plus de poids
sur les fédérations sur les ligues mais
ils sont en train de préparer une loi
sur le sport qui peut être va sortir à
l'automne
enfin là aussi on dit que ça va pas être
possible enfin bon espérons que ce soit
est dedans il ya il ya en tout cas un
pavé sur la gouvernance du sport donc
notamment la limitation du nombre de
mandats voilà trois maximum la
limitation peut-être aussi d'âge d'arc
comme c'est le cas au cnosf après
soixante dix ans j'avais plus droit de
vous présenter donc les élections parce
qu'elle s'en fait est-ce qu'elles sont
faites par les clubs eux-mêmes ou est-ce
qu'elles sont faites par des grands
barons qui sont présidents de ligues et
de comités et le code du sport qu'est ce
qu'on en fait parce que dans le code du
sport il ya des des lois je pense
notamment l'article l 212 9 nul ne peut
exercer à titre rémunéré ou bénévoles
s'il a fait l'objet d'une condamnation
or on voit certains bénévoles qui sont
restées difficiles qu'on voit intervenir
à l'autre bout de la france
sauf qu'on peut pas vérifier pour un
bénévole c'est ça le souci pour
quelqu'un qui est rémunérée on peut
vérifier parce qu'il a une carte
professionnelle c'est les directions
départementales et là il pourra donner
cette carte professionnelle vous êtes
obligés d'avoir vérifié le volume de
volée 2 et jusqu'à présent il n'y avait
pas aussi cette volonté de vérifier si
on est dans la volonté de chercher les
choses d'où l'attestation d'honorabilité
qui va être demandé aux bénévoles en
attendant qu'on puisse éventuellement
croiser avec les fichiers figé est ce
qu'il ya des sports cibler plus que
d'autres parce qu'on a vu l'enquète
disclose parle de 28 sports avec
d'autres chiffres également 276 victimes
77' de notre
numéro d'appel de prise en charge et
d'accompagnement des victimes
on a vraiment une panoplie immense si on
peut dire de tous les sports olympiques
pas olympique confidentiel non
confidentielle que ça soit individuelle
collective et quel que soit le niveau
départemental régional régional
olympique
tout est touché c'est pas une question
de sport dépendance est une question de
prédateurs sexuels dépendants les
prédateurs pour les prédateurs sexuels
c'est plus ces pratiques le monde du
sport parce qu ils s'infiltrent vers le
toucher werlen team de la tête c'est
beaucoup plus facile en sport qu'en
musique qu'à l'éducation nationale dans
le second il ya quand même deux fois
plus d'agressions sexuelles que dans
dans le monde hors sport donc si le
prédateur sexuel est bon tennis il va à
la fédé tennis il est bon en cuir d'une
bâton et ben il va la fédé de curling
bâton c'est tout simple donc il faut pas
incriminer les fédérations le sport
spécifique ça n'a rien à voir quel rôle
de lapins des parents également parce
qu'il ya des parents qui peuvent
investir beaucoup les parents qui se
disent les les enfants vont se dire mais
bon beaucoup investi je veux pas leur
faire de la peine je vais pas leur dire
tu récurrent chez les enfants ne pas
vouloir faire de la peine à ses parents
et on voit même des décos quand les
parents sont au courant de ce qui s'est
passé au niveau de leurs enfants
il ya eu certes un suicide donc c'est
vraiment en toute connaissance de cause
que les enfants aussi ne parle pas à
leurs parents parce que parce qu'ils ont
peur de leur faire de la peine mais le
rôle des parents c'est d'abord même
quand l'enfant est dans un paul est
interne est allé à l'insep enfin peu
importe il faut maintenir le lien
il faut maintenir le lien avec avec son
enfant il ne faut pas être culpabilisé
ans et essayé essayé bon ça c'est
difficile un mais deux pas faire un
transfert pour être un futur champion
sur le sur le podium c'est hyper
important
mais l'aide alors le livre d'un sarah
abitbol l'expliquent très très bien dans
son dessin le lait par an et que
effectivement un moment donné elle peut
pas parler parce qu'il ya ce sens et oui
il ya toute cette attente de la part des
parents tout cet investissement en plus
ils ont déménagé eux c'est très bien
expliqué donc oui oui il ya tout ça bien
évidemment que tout le monde tout le
monde j'ai envie de dire à une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe mais
et mais voilà mais je voudrais pas non
plus faire croire enfin excusez moi je
préfère quand même me dire que tu
oublies sportif est comme ça parce que
là on est en train de dresser un tableau
on a l'air de dire que tous nous
représente tous la majorité des parts
dans tous les clubs il faut dénoncer
mais il faut aussi être cinq mois je
fais partie de ceux et celles qui
considèrent que ce n'est jamais tout
blanc ni jamais tout noir mais que bien
souvent la règle et est entre les deux
donc le sport c'est génial mais il ya
aussi des revers il ya aussi sa part
d'ombré donc essayer de pardon mais ben
il faut pas y mater oui combattre avec
votre numéro de téléphone vous pouvez le
donner
oui c'est le 01 45 33 85 62 était une
ligne d'appel qui à disposition des
sportifs et sportives victimes de
maltraitance ou discrimination et il est
à disposition sept jours sur sept de 8
heures à 22 heures et ce sont des
professionnels qui vous prennent en
charge qui vous accompagnent
concrètement qui vous rencontrent des
médecins des psychologues des avocats
des assistantes sociales et des
gendarmes dans vos régions
merci beaucoup véronique le bar et
béatrice barbusse d'avoir répondu
une question sur arte france l'autre
match thème sensible mais il fallait en
parler merci beaucoup à vous d'être
d'être venu vous pouvez évidemment
revivre cette émission sur arte france
point tv en podcast ou en replay et puis
on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'autre match au bail
[Musique]